luke weber oh and three and eleven eight
five era he has been pitching not so
well for the diamondbacks as planted had
some forearm stiffness so he's gone
short of those last two starts the asf
two on and nobody out and olson's coming
up on the ground and fair christian
walker is going to have to settle for
one thought about two but he was too far
up the line and they finally do get
their first out as simeon moves into
third and la riana's at second so second
and third one down the big third baseman
matt chapman
gonna miss 97 on that fastball a big out
number two for luke weaver how big a
lift would it be to get canner right
here oh huge can of swings hits one to
right
on comes calhoun he gets there and he's
got it in fair territory crosses the
foul line so the a's are denied they
failed to score with the diamondbacks
coming up in the bottom half right hand
to frankie montas is your athletic
starting pitcher today 27 year old right
hander who has held the opposition to
two or fewer runs in all four starts
this year old calhoun knocks one into
the gap on the first pitch he sees
that's going to get to the wall
good start for the diamondbacks calhoun
a leadoff double so they're on the
corners one out for last night's
walk-off hero david peralta
that one gets by murphy here comes
calhoun one-nothing diamondbacks
that's the first first inning run that
montage has allowed this year so two
inches and two walks in the inning have
loaded them up for eduardo
this first pitch swinging after montaus
walked two guys in a row grossman and
foul ground here comes starling
and he's in there they throw to third
and peralta's in there as well
aggressive base running by the
diamondbacks and they lead it to nothing
second and they're two out and here is
nick ahmed hitting seventh in the order
today ahmed hits a fly ball left field
grossman backing up it's gone nick ahmed
that's his third and it's five nothing
diamondbacks he did not miss it long
home run to left field and the pitch to
uh far show here it is swan got lifted
left field line and coming on grossman
is right there to make the catch and the
inning is over but the d-backs get the
jump on the a's on this tuesday so
murphy a right-handed hitter 222 two
home runs three rbis right field line
and that is going to be fair
biscotti digging for third and they're
going to wave them home here comes the
throw to the plate and it is late and
the a's are on the board and the tree
two to symbion is driven in the air to
right
calhoun is back
shy of the warning track makes the catch
that'll end the inning but the age get a
run back cole calhoun starts off the
second against right hander frankie
bonetons
now and hits one high and deep left
center field that ball's carrying cole
calhoun
takes it out of here that's his seventh
they get the run back and it's six to
one and they're loaded with two outs for
ahmed who homered his first time up
ahmed base hit
peralta will score here comes walker
this is going to score two runs they've
got escobar hung up and chapman dropped
the ball
eight to one diamondbacks two more rbis
for nick ahmed that's five already for
nick five in the first three in the
second so far lamb's got a base hit
and they'll keep going escobar's home
it's an rbi single for jake and it's
nine to one here's the 2-2 pitch again
divorce show and he swings and misses
the diamondbacks send nine to the play
meaning calhoun will lead it off in the
third inning olson grounded out his
first time up today
waves at a fastball and weaver gets his
second strikeout two down here it is
from weaver got him swinging up and in
with a fastball he struck him out twice
two strikeouts in the inning and three
for weaver luke today has walked one so
far punch down three luke weaver at 95
has struck out the last three batters
he's faced one down in this fourth the
2-2 pitch to him and he struck him out
swinging at 97 with the eight so the
last two innings four strikeouts for
weaver this has been the perfect
scenario for luke and for torrey lavello
they got him that early lead five in the
first four more in the second
round to center right at starling martin
two down in the fifth here comes the 3-2
pitch to simeon and he struck him out
swinging and weaver a little emotion
knowing he'd gotten through five here he
ends up striking out six with a widener
out there to start the sixth in relief
of luke weaver
got him on a fastball right down the
middle clocked at 95 a strikeout of
l'oreal one down
a strike three called and two strikeouts
here for widener to start his day two up
two down to the six
swing and a miss canada down on strikes
that'll end the inning so weiner strikes
out the sun for the watch
the new homert here last night over two
so far today
we're gonna miss taylor widener has
faced five batters he's got four
strikeouts one down in the seven
bringing home the o2 to biscotti struck
him out swinging at 96 two up two down
2-2 from widener to kemp
and a fly ball to center right at the
castro he's got it
side retired in order for taylor widener
the combo of luke weaver and taylor
widener have been tough on the age today
seven innings they have struck out 11
between them and a swing of the miss he
has now struck out six of the seven he
has retired
popped up on the infield
escobar backing out shala right calling
for it and eduardo makes a catch
widener's work three scoreless innings
here one out and here is la castro
castro to center mariano's out there you
won't get it here comes john jay le
castro's right on his heels john jay
will score and make it 10-1 an rbi
double for tim lacastro
juan lopez just up from the alternate
team he's on demand to pitch the knife
escobar has one and two when the
diamondbacks
have another win